ذلك وصل فريق من الاطباء المتطوعين في
الهلال الاحمر القطري الى منطقه شمال غربي
سوريا من معبر باب الهوى الحدودي مع تركيا
وقال مراسل الجزيره من الفريق مكون من 12
طبيبا من مختلف التخصصات لدعم القطاع
الطبي في المناطق المنكوبه جراء الزلزال
هدفنا ووصولنا هنا الى باب الهوى في
الجانب السوري معنى فريق طبي متواجد معنا
من عدد من الاطباء
متخصصين في عدد من التخصصات المهمه حقيقه
تخصصات في الجراحه العامه
بتخصص بالاطفال ايضا بالنساء ايضا جراحات
التجميليه ايضا عندنا طبيب نفسي ايضا
موجود معنا فكل هذه التخصصات صراحه جزاهم
الله خير تبرعوا ضمن فريق الهلال انه
ياتوا يقدموا هذا الدعم الصحي
للمحتاجين داخل الاراضي السوريه
تم شحنها من دوله قطر سيتم ادخالها ان شاء
الله الى داخل السوري فان شاء الله باذن
الله يعني او ايضا عندنا فرق اخرى ايضا
راح تاتي تباعا